welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navaro and I'm going to tell you
all about the 2006 Marvel Comics event
Annihilation why because now that we're
living in a post Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 world we may end up seeing some
of these Modern Marvel Classics
influence the direction of the cosmic
side of the MCU so put your speculating
hats on and get ready to tell me in the
comments what you think is going to be
pulled from these Marvel Comics one more
reminder before I start I am going into
spoil territory so if you're even a
teeny get intrigued by what these
awesome Comics have to offer go read
them for yourself Marvel even has a
reading order you can use with Marvel
unlimited so fire up those Guardians
movie scores to listen to while reading
and off you go let's begin the
annihilation storyline was an event that
took the majority of Marvel's space
fairing characters and brought them all
together to tell an epic story that was
happening at the same time as Marvel's
Civil War was on Earth which really made
that Superhero conflict seem like small
potatoes compared to what kind of
threats characters were dealing with
literally everywhere other than the
planet Earth it's like Tony Steve get
over your we got real problems
that we may need to deal with here
before the main Annihilation series took
place we were treated to a bunch of tiin
series that helped set up where certain
characters would be during the
annihilation so up first is a draxx the
Destroyer series with a story called
earthfall on Annihilation dayus 41
prison transport vessel carrying
Galactic class criminals on its way to
the Kiln crashes on Earth near cots
Bluff Alaska popul
2,816 so it's a pretty small town the
next day a 10-year-old Taran girl named
Cammy who comes from an abusive home
explores the woods and finds escaped
alien convicts led by pach the power
scroll a deadly enemy of the Fantastic
Four who was also genetically engineered
and given some superpowers but not
exactly like the super scroll Cammy also
meets Drax the Destroyer who confuses
the human girl for his daughter who Drax
originally believed was killed by Thanos
but who survived and grew up to be the
the hero and Avenger moon dragon Drax is
kind of messed up in the head a bit
because before this comic series Drax
was a huge beefed up boy a very overly
exaggerated very 9s Arnold
Schwarzenegger type of character who
himself was genetically engineered to
take on Thanos but who also wasn't very
smart but the ship's crash coupled with
some Singularity Drive plasma that Drax
was dumb enough to drink have been
slightly changing how Drax is thinking
and speaking then paybox shape changes
into Thanos to distract draxx and the
other space Criminal will straight up
murder him so now Drax is dead and Cammy
tricks some aliens into believing that
pach gave her drax's body that night
after smoke starts coming out of drax's
corpse a new smaller more tattooed Drax
bursts out of the older drax's chest
Drax is reborn looking much more like
the Drax were all familiar with restored
and once again the Destroyer Drax
mentally uses cammy's mind to refresh on
everything that recently happened and
tells her he's putting up with her
because she reminds him of his daughter
Cammy sticks with drag because well
she's got nothing else going on for her
in life then in an abandoned clothing
store Drax puts on some leather pants
with a design that matches his tattoo
somehow and then takes out the alien
criminals that were terrorizing cot's
Bluff before getting to piyok the scroll
reveals that he called the Omega core
the pan galactic peacekeeping Force
tasked with delivering criminals to the
Kiln to come pick them all up and
because Cammy unknowingly bonded with
draxx and because her mother was killed
by the invading aliens she leaves Earth
behind and accompanies the Destroyer
where they're both taken into custody
along with pach then in the annihilation
prologue one shot we're at Annihilation
day minus 7 where Thanos the Mad Titan
is waiting for something with two
escaped prisoners from the Kiln screet a
chaos might and possibly the last
surviving member of her species one of
the first species to come into existence
after the big bang and the extremely
powerful Fallen One World eater
galactus's very first ever Herald who
Thanos had mentally enslaved to become
his Herald the trio are joined by death
the Cosmic entity who personifies the
concept of death itself in the form of a
little girl who tells Thanos that she's
with whoever's coming and who's coming
knows her intimately and that it's
something wonderful then boom
Annihilation day a fleet of insect-like
ships emerg from the crunch the
intersection between the positive and
negative matter universes and the power
source of the Kiln and tear through the
Kiln prison along with millions of
Worlds Annihilation day plus 7even at
the home planet of the Nova core Taran
Richard Ryder reports for Duty along
with a rellian and a Centurian and
elsewhere the ship transporting Drax and
Camy comes through and they're let go
because Drax is technically a new being
and not responsible for his past drax's
past crimes while prisoner pach looks on
as a novacore gets briefed about the
event at the Crunch and believe the
invading threat is still two star
systems away Drax senses something's
about to happen so grabs Cammy and bust
through security at that very same
moment the Invaders appear and start
destroying the entire Spaceport Drax and
Cammy barely make it to an escape pod
and Richard Ryder and the rest of the
Nova cor get absolutely overwhelmed with
the insect-like attackers the Spaceport
is destroyed the Centurion that Richard
bonded with is killed and after xandar
is demolished Richard is the last
surviving member of the Nova cor
Annihilation day plus 12 in disputed
territory of cre scroll systems Ronan
the Accuser is arrested by other cre
officers to face court marshall for
crimes of sedition against the cre
Empire Ronin goes willingly Annihilation
day plus 15 the Silver Surfer former
Herald of Galactus is peacefully
enjoying space when he senses an
infestation at the cre star base Yan rag
cert the super scroll is using his
powers of invisibility to EES drop on
cre soldiers being super racist towards
Scrolls where he also learns that the
invading enemies have a weapon called
the Harvester of Sorrow that can destroy
entire planets and is moving toward the
scroll Empire and back at the former
xandar cluster orbit the annihilation
wave begins Supply and support protocols
while erratica first concubine to his
will reports to her ruler on their
status her ruler being anilis the living
death that walks from the Negative Zone
and usually enemy of the Fantastic fort
in this story he's really been upgraded
to full-on threat to the entire Marvel
Universe best of luck to Our Heroes
they've got their work cut out for him
next up is Annihilation Nova where we go
back a bit to Annihilation day plus 11 4
days after the xandarian cluster was hit
by the annihilation wave and in the
ruins of xandar the last survivor of the
Nova courp Richard Ryder w up to someone
talking to him the world mind the class
G Collective artificial sentience
created to govern and maintain all of
xandarian culture helps Richard barely
survive fighting off a few of anil's bug
alien troops and then leads Richard to
the hub where the world mind is
physically located in order to preserve
xandarian culture after their Extinction
and to best assist with the threat of
annihilist the worldmind asks Richard to
download its entire self as well as the
cosmic power source called the Nova
Force into Richard's mind and body
because only a Nova can and he's the
last one Richard allows it gets a
kick-ass new suit upgrade to help him
become Nova Prime and then takes his
frustration out on the nearby
Annihilation wave testing his increased
power levels and losing control even
annihilist on his Command Ship feels it
Richard crashes onto the ruins of xandar
and he runs into draxx and Cammy Richard
then reluctantly takes them with him as
he tries to find a ship off of xandar
while avoiding using his new powers for
fear of losing control like he did draxx
fights off some bugs while Richard tries
to take Cammy to safety then Richard
throws Drax his helmet SL hat and Drax
Converses with the worldmind agreeing to
help Richard learn focus and
self-control the trio finds a Nova ship
to escape in and Richard attempts to
open a Stargate inside Xander's
atmosphere which would normally destroy
the world but it's already been
destroyed so they pull it off and escape
to a planet nine light years away their
ships breaking apart but they're rescued
by Taran hero wielder of the quantum
bands and former Avenger quaza Richard
Ryder tells quazar that xandar has been
destroyed and he's the last Nova Left
quazar tells Richard he's trying to help
in evacuating this planet full of 18.6
million colonists and could use his help
Drax tells quazar that Richard is loaded
has the entire Nova Force downloaded
into him but that he's unsure of using
his powers Drax also tells Cammy that
they're sticking close to Nova where
it's smart to be near that much power
because of what's coming and just
moments after evacuation efforts get
underway with some helpful assistance an
advaned Scout of the annihilation wave
arrives and starts attacking quazar
immediately flies into action and Nova
gets his head in the game to follow
Richard then attempts an upper magnitude
Stargate to help evacuate all the
colonists at once 2.7 light years away
annihilus once again feels that
gravimetric event and heads to the
source of that power as the refugees are
making their way through an nihilus'
Flagship arrives and punches through a
colonist Convoy ship with draxx
recognizing anilus and quazar and Nova
being scattered quazar tries to get him
to back off but Nova is dead set on
hitting the an a wave head on and with
the world mind helping him well Nova is
a force to be reckoned with it's
seriously epic and then right when we
think Richard might take a hit quazar
arrives to back him up and it is awesome
guys you got to read these Comics I'm
telling you then from the surface of the
planet Drax uses a Subic link to
communicate with Nova telling him to hit
the heart of the wave annihilus himself
and Richard doesn't even know who anilus
is both he and quazar hit the command
ship and confront anilist but Nova gets
easily thrown back annihilus then kills
quazar and takes his Quantum band Nova
is down but not out coming back with a
devastating blow to annihilist risking
getting too close to the living death
that walks but taking a chance so that
the world M can upload orders to the
annihilation wave to attack itself and
it works Nova can barely stand so he
Retreats and escapes anilist orders his
wave to self-destruct and to regroup in
another sector and a barely alive
Richard Ryder tells the world mind that
he's not going to deliver it to a safe
place instead Richard is going to use
the worldmind to attack anilus again and
the world mind agrees draxx and Cammy
find a floating Nova and bring him on
board where Richard promises to help
Drax with another Stargate to escape in
return for lessons in how to
destroy one shot energy huh okay I'll
try
it oh
[Applause]
yeah whoa what do one shot's Focus Che
do
see
eternally waa one shot really is all you
need begin your transformation with one
shot energy today by going to onshot
energy.com new rockstars for 10% off
your order then in Annihilation Silver
Surfer we're back at the ruins of xandar
on Annihilation day plus 17 norin rad
former Herald of galatis surveys the
horrific destruction and comes upon
ravenous pack alpha seeker and annihilus
is second in command as he attacks
Gabriel the air Walker a surviving
xandarian and another former Herald of
Galactus ravenous explains to the surfer
that he was sent by anilist to try and
find all the former Heralds to capture
them for his master and then attacks the
Silver Surfer with the negative zones
counterpart to the positive universe's
power Cosmic which ravenous calls the
essence the Silver Surfer manages to
rescue Gabriel from the villains and
transports himself and the Droid light
years away before ravenous curs bred to
be sensitive to the Herald's unique
energy signature can track them down
Gabriel shows the surfer what happened
on xandar and succumbs to his fatal
injuries the surfer then destroys
Gabriel's body to ensure that ravenous
doesn't claim it elsewhere in the
Andromeda galaxy Thanos observes the
unfolding events and sends his Herald
the Fallen one to bring the Seekers to
Thanos to form an alliance and in the
scroll Empire in the ruins of tala prime
the Silver Surfer surveys more death and
destruction which he realizes holds no
meaning and vows to stop annihilus
Annihilation day plus 19 at the eloran
reach in the scroll Empire yet another
former Herald of Galactus terax the
Tamer comes across Seekers sent to
capture him seven light years away the
Silver Surfer makes his way through
another scroll world destroyed by the
wave he only finds One Survivor and
Promises to take him to safety on an
nihilus' Command Ship ravenous brings
Thanos of Titan to meet with his master
where annihilus explains to Thanos that
he's invaded the positive matter
Universe because his negative matter
universe is dying the positive matter
universe is expanding into the negative
zone so anilus is taking back what he
believes is rightfully his back with the
Silver Surfer Seekers arrived to try and
capture him when two more former Heralds
xandarian generator of cosmic flame Fire
Lord and wielder of two Cosmic swords
red shift show up and Kill The Seekers
against the pacifist Surfers wishes
meanwhile in the bedon hegemony galatis
tells his current Herald Stardust that
he senses a universal imbalance the
surfer fir Lord and red shift agree to
take the Survivor to Safe routes while
terax has been captured by the wave and
Thanos tells screet he's only allying
with anilus for as long as he feels like
it classic Thanos that bastard classic
Thanos Annihilation day plus 20 Fallen
one heads back to the ruins of the Kiln
sent by Thanos to see if a former
Potential Threat is dead or alive when
he gets taken by tenius and egis
terrible giant beings with power on par
with Galactus who countless Millennia
ago were imprisoned by Galactus himself
inside the Kiln prison and who were set
free on Annihilation day the beings can
smell galactus's energy on the Fallen
one and plan to question him to get
revenge on their imprisoner many
galaxies away after the former Heralds
deliver the Soul Survivor to safety
galactus's current Herald Stardust a
cosmic being made up of cosmic energy
appears and tells the surfer that
Galactus requests his presence the
surfer agrees and heads to Galactus
questioning why the world eater would
only request his presence and not demand
making the surfer think that Galactus is
desperate or fearful after the surf Sur
for leaves the annihilation wave tracks
the other Heralds and arrives attacking
the refugees so the Heralds including
Stardust fight back on anila's Flagship
he and his technicians have been trying
to transfer biological power Cosmic so
that anilist can wield it most recently
from the body of morg yet another former
Herald of Galactus at this point i' lost
count how many the guys had sorry morg
was once a simple executioner who defied
Galactus until he chose him as a Herald
Thanos tells annihilist he may be able
to help him for a price Annihilation
date plus 20 1 the Silver Surfer arrives
at the devour of Worlds and Galactus
explains to the surfer that he was the
one to imprison egis and tenius and that
he can feel that they are free Galactus
is asking the surfer to be his Herald
once again to help him defeat the
universal threats and he offers to
restore the surfer's untold cosmic power
even remove the remorse that plagues him
but the Silver Surfer demands to keep
that remorse and Humanity before the
process can be completed ravenous who
had been tracking the surfer appears
with Annihilation forces the surfer is
reborn and decimates the forces ravenous
and his opposing Force the essence
believe he's a match for the surfer's
power Cosmic but the Silver Surfer
attaches his enemy to his board and
sends it flying through space for 3
hours then the surfer catches up with
ravenous after creating a new board and
fights him to submission demanding that
he return to the negative Zone and never
come back afterwards he resumes his
mission acting as the herald of Galactus
who must feed the surfer plans to steer
Galactus clear of annihilist so that
lives will be saved Annihilation day
plus 40 on an unaffiliated Colony World
Thanos is summoned by tenius and egis
both of whom screet recognizes they give
Thanos back the body of his Herald
Fallen one in exchange for information
on where to find Galactus and Thanos
forms yet another Alliance in
Annihilation super scroll on
Annihilation day plus 41 on a peaceful
jewel in the crown of the scroll Empire
Annihilation forces led by cunning
strategist senior Admiral Salo who's in
command of the Harvester of Sorrow touch
down to find only beautiful Wilderness
until the trees reveal them themselves
as scroll soldiers in Disguise fighting
back for the scroll Empire unfortunately
for the Scrolls they're no match for the
power of the annihilation wave but
fortunately for them cert the super
scroll is there and he is a match for
the annihilations forces Admiral Salo
then deploys the Harvester an energy
being that can break down an entire
planet into its basic organic elements
killing everyone on the surface
Annihilation forces included except for
cert who uses his powers to escape
Annihilation day plus 46 after days of
hard flight cert found himself on the
bridge of a scroll dreadn led by one of
the many Warlords who now control the
remnants of the scroll Empire baroness
saach clert asked for assistance in
taking down the Harvester of Sorrow but
sabach refused not wanting to risk her
position on what she considered a
suicide mission she then insulted kert
pointing out his many many failures
against Earth's Heroes kert couldn't
keep his anger in check so he attacks
the baroness and is forced to flee the
ship and fight off a scroll Armada
single-handedly fully expecting to be
killed kert is surprised when he's
rescued by a young scroll mechanic and
engineer named Rakin who's idolized the
super scroll his whole life after his
father fought alongside cert in the
Battle of Haron then the baroness
broadcasts a fleetwide transmission
putting a bounty of 3 million golden
zela on the super scroll's head that's a
lot is aax kert tells Rin they're going
to put a team together to stop the
Harvester before it can get to the
scroll Capital where Ker's son currently
lives and who are they going to recruit
can't be from the scroll Empire so it's
going to have to be from the Negative
Zone itself Annihilation day plus 47 the
easier way to go to the negative zone is
to go to Earth and to the backer
building and to find Reed Richards who
throws up some defensive measures but
actually listens to alert and his plan
Mr Fantastic agrees to help and the
super scroll and Rakin head into an
nihilus' home demension Annihilation day
plus 48 cert and Rin commandeer a vessel
in the negative Zone throwing its six
innocent passengers out of the ship
Annihilation day plus 52 Rin Witnesses
cert torture and kill beings in the
negative Zone to obtain information
about the Harvester even killing the
being who told clert the location of the
scientist who built it and who may know
how to destroy it Rin confronts the
super scroll about his honor and clert
gets defensive explaining that he's
doing what needs to be done just like
rin's father who died at the Battle of
Haron Annihilation day plus 55 kert and
Rakin head to a prison planetoid where
the scientist who built the Harvester of
Sorrow is in charge and the super scroll
tears through their defenses eventually
taking out all the negative Zone aliens
defending this scientist cert demands
that he reveal how to stop the Harvester
to which the alien replies that he can
design a virus to kill it as the
Harvester is a living thing and before
clert can take his captive away he's
interrupted by some of the prison's
inmates looking for revenge on their
Jailer including the multiplying when
hit super strong prak and the Luminous
and Powerful Android praxagora the last
of her kind after a brief fight kert
convinces the convicts to become his
army in his fight against annihilist
Annihilation day plus 65 Rakin lets cert
know that he doesn't have enough
manpower to finish a portal built to
read Richard's specifications to escape
the Negative Zone and intercept the
Harvester of Sorrow back in the positive
matter Universe clert then strikes prak
enough times to multiply enough manow
Annihilation day plus 66 kert kills the
scientist once the virus is complete he
then delivers a speech to his assembled
Army of freed prison inmates and even
grants rin's request to Pilot the ship
that will deliver the killing blow to
the Harvester clert later tells
praxagora why he wants to save the
scroll Planet he chose to save zagna
it's because his son lives there and he
now understands his honor for the Empire
isn't as important as the honor for his
son and family praxagora makes a move on
cert and he rejects her sorry girl
Annihilation day plus 68 at zagna at the
heart of the scroll Empire the battle
with the annihilation wave rages and all
seems lost until the Super scroll and
his small army punch through a portal
and turn the tide but the missile
carrying the virus that could destroy
the Harvester of Sorrow never comes
because Rakin betrays kert instead the
super scroll wakes up on Admiral salo's
Ship in time to see rin's betrayal and
worse to see the Harvester atomize the
planet zagna and murder Ker's son kert
is totally devastated but he still
gathers the strength to utilize one
superpower Admiral Salo didn't count on
his power of telepathic hypnosis that's
telekinesis cert the super scroll uses
it on Rakin before he can leave the
ship's Bridge commanding him to release
the prisoners Rakin does but manages to
run away the super scroll kills the
Admiral and praxagora stays behind to
destroy the entire ship from the bridge
kert finds Rin and demands to know why
he betrayed him Rin infers it was partly
because his father died while being led
by cert but also because he learned how
to survive by watching The Vicious super
scroll I learned it from watching you
Dad kert tells Rin that millions of
Scrolls including his son died because
of his actions so he burns off his Limbs
and leaves him to die praxagora
witnesses her fellow prisoner who she
loved like a brother prak and all his
duplicates finally die at the hands of
the annihilation drones before praxagora
is killed as well cert arrives in time
to save her they fight fight their way
to the bowels of the Harvester where
praxagora intends to release the
infinite amounts of heat inside of her
the power of the singularity to destroy
the ship but the super scroll instead
doesn't let her make the sacrifice for
his cause so he absorbs her infinite
heat with his powers kisses her and
leaves her the strength to find an
escape pod Annihilation day plus 7,300
in the scroll system on new zagna 20
years since kert sacrificed himself we
see that praxagora is recounting the
tale of the heroic super scroll as
children listen on and the crowd chants
cert cert cert in Annihilation Ronin we
catch up with Ronin the former accuser
on Annihilation day plus 88 months after
his trial since he's been on the run
from CRE Authority seeking those who
testified against him on a planet in the
cre system Ronan is still accusing
passing judgment on a murderer by
sentencing him to trial by combat with
Velociraptors which is a great example
of why comic books rule Ronan later
hears from his contact with this
murderer who was leader of his clan gone
a power vacuum was left behind and
rioting has already begun for leadership
of that Clan Ronan doesn't care because
he was only on that planet to track down
a witness in his trial a rellian named
Tana Nile who once spent time on Earth
disguised as a human as Jane Foster's
roomate as Tana was helping to select
planets to absorb into the rellian
Empire once he gets the info he needs
Ronan heads back to his ship through
some riots but there are no sweat for
him we flash back to ronan's trial on
Annihilation day plus 29 where Tana
testified and claims Ronan was colluding
to overthrow the heads of the cre Empire
to help parts of the cre Empire be
absorbed into the scroll Empire back in
the present on Annihilation day plus 95
Ronan lands on a planet called godthab
Omega and finds his old friend the
brilliant cyber geneticist Kora the
pursuer kath has been living in Exile
the remnants of the cre Star Force and
he never believed the rumors of Ronan
betraying the Empire suddenly their meal
is interrupted by an explosion and two
warrior women appear the super strong
owner of living Living Armor Stellaris
and the adopted daughter of Thanos the
cybernetic Scourge nebula and then on
Mount verago we see the deadliest woman
in the universe gamor as she promises to
break Ronin across the hemisphere in the
township of Abyss an enhanced Warrior
determined to bring about Galactic peace
DeVos the Devastator confronts Taos the
Untamed a scroll born without the
ability to shape change who later became
cybernetically enhanced while a
mysterious hooded being watches on back
to the fight with Ronin and the warrior
women the former accuser is able to take
down Stellaris and nebula and Kath later
explains their leader gamor may now take
matters into her own hands on Mount
verago nebula tells gamor how Ronan
bested Stellaris and her in combat and
then Tanana Nile one of gamora's Graces
reveals why Ronan is here for her Ronin
marches off to confront gomorah and Kath
questions his motives Ronan admits he
felt a pull to this planet God Fab Omega
and he doesn't know what it is Kath
mentions that there is a population boom
in Abyss so Ronin makes his way there in
Abyss DeVos defeats Taos when Ronan
approaches asking him to join forces to
investigate what is wrong with this
world before DeVos can agree gamor stabs
him through the back and she and Ronin
start their fight and the Mysterious
hooded figure is some distance away
revealed to be glorian a former tan who
was given the ability to reshape reality
when he was Apprentice to the shaper of
Worlds and who now has something to
prove gamor despite wearing what is a
really ridiculous outfit that surely
helps her in no way is able to face off
against Ronin with no problem she's
treated herself to something of a cosmic
makeover and she's proving it so Ronin
then decides to test the upper limits of
his Universal Weapon and their combined
energies are powering glorian to build
and rebuild the surface of the planet
while they captured DeVos and Taos look
on during the fight Ronan is really
feeling himself and declares that he is
now Ronan the free and then gomorah
introduces her friend the godslayer the
battle rages on until Ronan remembers
his need to clear his name delaying the
fight in a for Kath to rescue his friend
Kath also tells Ronan of a massive
Invasion Force heading for the cre
Empire that he learned of from ronan's
prior contact and that Ronin is needed
by his people Ronan agrees but before
they can make plans to head to Hala the
annihilation wave arrives on godthab
Omega Annihilation day plus 99 for 4
days the annihilation wave has been
destroying every corner of the planet
but Ronin believes the Unseen Puppeteer
glorian can be made to turn his
attention on the Invaders instead of the
powerful Denis of the Galaxy that he's
been drawing in to use in his reality
reshaping and almost as soon as Ronin
locates glorian erratica first concubine
to anilus attacks Ronin bringing them
both into glorian hideout with eratica
fighting the new shaper of Worlds Ronan
recruits DeVos and Taos to his cause
Gamora meanwhile makes it back to Mount
verago sensing that even her anger and
emotions have been manipulated by
glorian and Promises to avenge The
Graces that had been killed by the wave
which include the highly skilled lupoid
Warrior Spirit later Ronan makes it to
mount verago in time to see Tana Nile
dying from wounds inflicted by the wave
and he learns her false testimony was
bought by the corrupt Cree leadership
house Fierro before she can name a
specific Cree she dies gomorah then
joins with Ronin to get revenge on the
Puppeteer who made them battle but when
they head back to Abyss they find that
goran's mind has been wiped clean
snapping from exerting enough power to
destroy the annihilation wave on godthab
Omega Ronin then vows to warn the cree
Empire of the incoming wave and gamorra
goes with him so finally we come to the
main Annihilation event Annihilation day
plus 204 and we're meeting back up with
Nova Richard Ryder who's now the United
fronts commander and chief holding back
the annihilation wave on the cre system
periphery Richard's number two is Peter
Quill who used to be Star-Lord and who's
very different from the version we're
used to this is a broken man and he and
Richard are working with gamor and
everyone else they can to fight this war
they're about to lose the right flank
when Ronin takes command of the aimless
cre soldiers there and orders a retreat
in orbit of the planet fir Lord red
shift and stardust are keeping their air
space clear and back down on the surface
Richard Dawns the Nova helmet to blast
into action catching up with draxx and
getting a hard truth from him the wave
is catching up to the wounded and if
Richard doesn't do what he's avoiding
doing they'll lose thousands instead of
just hundreds Richard calls down on
barrage command for a heavy ordinance
barrage sacrificing wounded cre soldiers
but potentially saving the rest of their
army Fire Lord meanwhile took the fight
to exteria most favored of the Lord
anilis and captured her to dis manle the
hive mind of the annihilation wave but
made himself vulnerable to attack 4
hours later Richard is briefed on what
went down while on annihilus Flagship
Thanos reveals he has enough to
successfully determine how to transfer
biological power Cosmic anilus orders
him to do so and in front of his two
remaining queens extermina and erratica
orders ravenous to kill the remaining
Heralds not capture them Annihilation
day plus 206 Nova and gamor are sleeping
with each other and Richard doesn't know
how it happened but he's glad it did he
leaves his bed to talk to Peter quill
who tells him firel Lord might be dead
the shiar are staying out of this
Universal conflict and the bedon are
keeping their heads down too Drax admits
to Cammy that the only reason he's
fighting in the war is to get at Thanos
and while Richard and Peter visit their
captive Queen exteria She reveals that
while they were fighting here elsewhere
the Silver Surfer and Galactus were
attacked by egis and tenias and one of
the scariest sentences in the Marvel
universe is uttered Galactus has fallen
Thanos with street was there to pick up
the pieces and now we know what he meant
when he said he had enough to study the
power Cosmic he has galatis y'all not
good Annihilation day plus 212 Cammy
finds Drax after he tried to lose the
Taran girl for the 12th time but cammy's
too smart for that another person also
finally locates Drax the genetically
engineered cre hero and newest holder of
the mantle of Captain Marvel Fila Vel
who tells Drax that her girlfriend and
his daughter moon dragon was taken
captive by Thanos Cammy says she thought
drax's daughter died and Drax explains
that his daughter Heather was killed but
she was reborn as moon dragon while
paying respects to her late Father the
Hero marll Fila and moon dragon were
attacked by Thanos and screet Thanos
ripped off Heather's ear for Fila to
deliver to Drax as a warning to keep
away from him but Drax tells Fila that
thanos's destruction is his Destiny he
won't stay away even for his daughter's
safety Camy keeps the ear meanwhile a
meeting between Nova Peter Quill Ronin
and the leadership of the cre Empire
house Fierro the same house that
apparently framed Ronin unjustly does
not end well as yep you guessed it Ronin
accuses them and yep you guess it kills
them all then gamor enters telling the
guys they need to go outside to meet
praxagora who brought them the body of
cert the super scroll a hero who
sacrificed himself to fight the
annihilation wave Ronan spits on the
space casket and then they're all
interrupted by ravenous who brought some
backup that includes piyok the power
scroll and a bug controlled terax the
Tamer gamor clocks the teleportation
energy signature the villain's use and
figures out they've allied with Thanos
her adopted father red shift and
stardust are summoned into battle but
immediately after that an even bigger
teleportation energy surge anil's
centurions arrive over a 100 powerful
warriors from over 100 worlds that
anilus has taken over the devastation is
total the battle is not going great red
shift and stardust try to form a path to
evacuation ships praxagora gets Ker's
body to safety Fila gets Peter Quill to
safety he tries to flirt but dude she's
gay and in orbit annihilist destroy some
of his own Fleet because of their
failure in taking this planet Thanos
then explains to the living death that
walk that they've repurposed Galactus
and his cosmic energy into a weapon for
the annihilation wave on the surface
ravenous fights Ronin into their medical
unit where Fire Lord wakes up from his
maybe death State it's confusing the
Heralds of Galactus operate on different
levels our heroes are regrouping to get
the hell off this planet and before
gomorah can take terax out of his misery
she's saved by Stardust who warns them
all that Galactus is here then Nova and
the others witness cert alive holding on
to firel Lord and Ronin thinking that
firel Lord and ravenous combined
energies brought him back somehow again
when you factor in the power Cosmic
stuff gets weird as our main characters
are escaping Camy is on a ship that Drax
stays behind to Ure can get off Planet
Drax has always pretended he doesn't
care but Peter Quill knows he did it for
Cammy galactus's energy is then used to
destroy the planet but Stardust and red
shift did as much as they could to
postpone that destruction they're
presumed dead so is draxx and the
remnants of the united front reconvene
near Earth where heroes are currently
fighting in a civil war so they aren't
even Ed for when the annihilation wave
is calculated to arrive in 3 months
Ronin with the Super Squirrel and
praxagora wants to take down house fero
of the cre on their own gamor cuts the
rest of the alliance loose because there
is no Alliance they lost she's pivoting
to Guerilla tactics probably for the
rest of her life which she's okay with
and Richard Ryder he's going to try and
assassinate annihilist all by himself
Annihilation day plus 218 Drax has been
killing his way through the annihilation
wave sneaking on board their ships and
taking out their forces one bug at a
time all to get to Thanos his Destiny
Annihilation day plus 220 Thanos
explains to annihilist the process of
drawing cosmic energy from dead planets
the wave destroys while barely keeping
Galactus alive and the surfer in stasis
and annihilus demands to siphon all of
it and leave none for the devour of
Worlds and his Herald after he leaves a
close by moon dragon suffering from the
same control bugs that were taking over
terax reveals to Thanos that anilis
considers him a Lackey and Thanos
doesn't care moon dragon then shows
Thanos the inside of anil's mind and it
proves that he's planning to wipe out
both universes this one and the Negative
Zone to rule all alone and in peace he's
turned galatis into a cosmic bomb and
Thanos had no idea back in the soul
system outside of Earth Peter Quill
tells Nova he's coming with him while
elsewhere in the universe Drax finds his
way onto erratica ship and kills her
kamora bids farewell to our
assassination Squad Nova Peter Quill Fel
and Cammy as they head back to the
xandar cluster to begin their mission
but the heroes also leave Cammy behind
for her safety meanwhile Thanos and
screet bring moon dragon to the machine
holding galatis so that Thanos and only
Thanos can shut it down and free him but
that is also exactly when draxx the
Destroyer would finally meet his mission
hunting down Thanos across a 100
galaxies arriving before the Mad Titan
Begins the shutdown process moon dragon
is all that stands between draxx and the
destruction of two universes so Thanos
quickly freeze her of the control bugs
so she can try and stall the Destroyer
it doesn't work Drax is too determined
and right before the final moment Thanos
sees mistress death and understands he's
about to die Drax plunges his fist
through thanos's chest and all Thanos
can say is interesting on a cre Fringe
system the remains of the united front
are getting help from anil's former
partner in crime blastar who gives Nova
coordinates to anil's Flagship moon
dragon tells Drax how badly he messed up
so he asks her to use her mental powers
to Stave off the waves forces while he
frees the Silver Surf ER the only other
being with enough power to pull off what
Thanos was trying to do and the Zen
laavian does it frees his master and
Galactus is pissed and on Hala the
capital planet of the cre Empire Ronin
kert and praxagora have been fighting
their way to the leaders of the Empire
the corrupt house Fierro and the super
scroll has maybe been enjoying killing
cre soldiers a little too much suddenly
anil's centurians arrive proving that
house Fierro has allied with the
annihilation wave our righteous Heroes
eventually make it into the complex with
a face off against ravenous and his curs
it's an epic battle involving all but
eventually Ronin accuses ravenous of
crimes against the cre Empire and finds
him guilty loyal cre soldiers round up
the cre traders who thought they were
doing the right thing allying with
anilus to spare their empire Ronin finds
them guilty and kills them then Ronin
makes his way into the chambers of the
Supreme intelligence who house Fierro
had placed in a living death not alive
and not able to die Ronan determines
this isn't the way of thec this
half-life so he ends the intelligence
and Ronin heads outside to the assembled
cre peoples chanting his name the name
of the new leader of the cre Empire
Annihilation day plus 222 this is an
important one a restored Galactus and
the Silver Surfer are decimating
annihilus forces true to his word to
Drax Galactus teleports drax's daughter
and Drax to safety on Hala ravenous
barely managed to escape to his ship in
orbit but is shocked to see how well the
cre begin fighting back and in the
wreckage of anil's Flagship after the
destruction from Galactus the living
death that walks is somehow still alive
but that's when Nova and quill and Fila
appear and Richard faces off against
annihilus on his own trapping his
friends behind a force field for their
protection the last Nova can barely hold
his own against anilus powered by the
late quazar Quantum bands until phel
gets free of the force field and touches
the bands on anil's wrists offering the
technology another option that isn't
evil and the bands choose Fila instead
in his last moments after losing the
bands that fueled him and surviving
galactus's attack drained him anilus
keeps flapping his jaw until Richard
realizes that's the Gap in his armor and
reaches down into anas's throat to rip
out his guts it's finally over Richard
Ryder collapses as he sees Lady Death
and Thanos in little matching outfits
it's very cute they're going to need
better luck next time though because
Richard refuses to die Annihilation day
plus 268 Armistice Day Richard survived
barely Peter Quill thinks Richard should
rebuild the novacore ravenous sued for
peace shortly after the galactic he and
the remaining Annihilation forces were
given certain Creed territories in
exchange for an end to the hostilities
Galactus and Silver Surfer are active
again more powerful and hungry than ever
before Fire Lord is hunting down the
centurions red shift and stardust were
killed in the war terax super scroll and
praxagora blastar and the space KN
resistance and even draxx are all
unaccounted for moon dragon Won't Give
Up the location of her father with the
quantum bands in her possession F Lael
is considering becoming the new quazar
and 10-year-old human girl Camy is
somewhere in the universe with screet
the chaos might on her shoulder
Armistice Day plus n on crar the former
capital planet of the cre Empire now in
the hands of the annihilation wave
extermina dies giving birth to a new
annihilus and in the two-issue epilog
series Annihilation Heralds of galatis
we go back a bit to Annihilation day
plus 222 the day that annihilist died
and in that very moment the control bugs
being used to manipulate Trax and pach
stop working Trax takes Revenge by
destroying the annihilation ship there
on sending them plummeting down onto a
planet in the wreckage terax and pyx
survive as they're pulled from the
wreckage by a Centurian inhabitant of
the planet who tells them her and other
survivors are being held by a power
hungry warlord terax is pretty over
power hungry Warlords so the next
morning using his powers of rock and
Earth control he confronts the warlord
and after a heated battle and the loss
of the Centurian who inspired the former
Herald to take this all on terax the
Tamer kills the warlord when the
remaining subjects then ask for terax to
rule in his stad he considers them
Unworthy of life unlike the Centurion
and destroys the planet and all who
lived on it pach manages to escape and
Trax flies off to begin rebuilding his
deadly reputation Annihilation day plus
227 Stardust uses the power Cosmic to
reform themselves and soon after is
confronted by the sole survivors of
their race the ethereals who were almost
all wiped out by the annihilation wave
they call Stardust a traitor for
abandoning their people and attack but
Stardust fights back and nearly kills
the ethereals until Stardust absorbs
them into their body carrying with them
the last of their people and race
Stardust then finds Galactus who is weak
from hunger and in a Showcase of
ultimate loyalty Stardust offers
Galactus the energies of the last of
their people which Galactus accepts and
decides to have two Heralds the Silver
Surfer and stardust to help with his
Intergalactic hunger Fire Lord frees a
fifth world from the potential control
of a centurion who were each gifted a
world to rule by ravenous on
Annihilation day plus 274 on a world
about to be fully under the control of a
corrupt Centurion other fellow
centurions not loyal to Ravenous or
annihilus cause strike out in an effort
to kill the corrupt one of their kind
before the fight can be concluded Fire
Lord arrives and with his power Cosmic
kills the corrupt Centurion but hears
the pleading of the others not loyal to
Ravenous Fire Lord decides to let them
go but not to Pardon them calling them
war criminals fire Lords own past
actions as the herald of Galactus have
focused him into doing good in his
present and future and tells the
centurions to do right or die Galactus
explains the origins of the universe and
the proemial gods to the Silver Surfer
and tasks him with finding egis Lord of
all sorrows and tenas of the darkness
between before they can destroy Galactus
Annihilation day plus 281 tenius and
egis are overseeing the wreckage of the
Kiln And discussing their plans to take
over the universe and impose their will
on the cosmic consonant that makes up
all reality the surfer observes this and
determines that he must hold them until
galatis can arrive to destroy them and
then an epic Beyond epic battle in the
Stars takes place the Silver Surfer is
nearly depleted of energy until he
decides to channel not only the energies
of the universe but of the nearby crunch
as well and he literally surfs the waves
of the essence of the creation event
overflowing the proemial gods and
killing them before galatis can arrive
impressed beyond anything ever before
the devour of Worlds fully restores
norin rad the Silver Surfer to be his
Herald once more and forever phew but
that's not all there's an entire sequel
called Annihilation Conquest that comes
after this and instead of annihilist
it's led by The Avengers longtime
robotic foe Ultron in space yep comment
below if you'd like me to break that one
down for you too the annihilation made
quite an impact on the Marvel Comics
universe and there was even a new series
of books called Annihilation skirge that
came out in 2019 and another called the
last annihilation in 2021 so odds are
good that this Cosmic focused event will
end up inspiring the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as for how
specifically well that's up to you to
speculate thanks again for letting me
talk Comics go read them and enjoy them
yourselves follow me over on Heroes
reforged on YouTube and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
bye